what's funny about this is that you
weren't at San Diego were you no right
so you were at San Diego for Comic-Con
and now you're here in Brazil for ccxp
when you were making the movie was it in
the contract that said I need to go to
places where I will be talking in front
of like 5 000 people at a time
um only the bit that I wrote in in
lipstick afterwards hoping that no one
would notice it's kind of been really
like crayon type after after print uh
but no one notice we've still got to go
here well being actually serious do you
enjoy getting in front of a crowd of
like three thousand or seven thousand
people and feeding off that energy or is
it a little bit nervous to actually
stand in front of so many people like
that I don't think it's I mean I come
from theater uh do you have you done
theater before yeah so it's like pretty
commonplace and this field to be in
front of large groups of people so I
don't I don't necessarily get nervous I
I feel like I'm less nervous when I am
being myself in front of a large group
of people rather than like doing lines
that someone else has given me oh I got
the complete opposite really like I'm
far less nervous the second there's a
script involved because then I know what
I'm meant to do and I know like what
you're meant to be communicating with
the audience like there's rules to the
game right like when it's being me and
particularly like us being us like it's
just a chaos field and so the chaos
field makes me very nervous so I've seen
obviously the trailer and I cannot I'm
so looking forward to this movie because
it looks so fun but mostly because John
and Jonathan are involved they're both
such talented filmmakers and I wanted to
know if you could talk a little bit
about collaborating with them because I
really do love their work I love them so
much game night is incredible
um it's like that conceit is so hard to
do and I feel like they did it so well
and they carry that Talent over to this
movie
um because when I read the script I I
didn't really know much about Dungeons
and Dragons I always wanted to play but
they managed to make a film that didn't
take itself too seriously but still had
weight and uh wasn't cynical I think the
word that they used last night at dinner
was they were like the movie's not
cynical like it actually is earnest you
know and I think yeah yes well what's
super rare about them is that they are
super small they are incredibly funny
they have a huge amount of love for the
world and yet they're not afraid of
earnestness and being able to be funny
without having some kind of victim butt
of the joke being able to be funny while
still Being Earnest while still caring
about the world caring about the
characters caring about that in a very
straightforward way is a skill that not
a lot of writers or filmmakers have and
I think that we're all Super Lucky to
kind of be in those hands in that
respect I've heard there's multiple
dragons in the movie
um and I'm just I've heard
um so what is it like fighting oh
because I'm assuming that you do fight a
dragon Dragon what is it like actually
filming fighting a dragon because to me
that's like the five-year-old dream come
true
um what is it like fighting a dragon
um
okay I'm trying not to like give
anything away
uh flappy things lizardy but in the air
Dragon no I know what a dragon is
he's not giving it away I'm trying not
to give away like
who fights dragons when dragons are
being thought if dragons are fun I mean
I think we got him we got at least one
in the trailer yeah right um is that the
is that is that a large red friend yes I
think so better
um find dragons is fun is is the
it genuinely is in in in my experience
because I think that's in the trailer
um
fighting dragons is literally that kind
of like 10 year old dream where you
swinging the sword around and like it's
this huge creature that's half in your
imagination
um and kind of half in the world because
also we have this really cool mix
between green screen elements and like
really and like cool practical elements
and like bits of puppetry kind of like
the gymnasts like half the time the
creatures in front of you are giving
scarily good performances like the way
that actors get competitive I got
competitive with the puppets I was like
nah you're not gonna act
um but it's it's a lot easier than you'd
think and at least twice as much fun
last question for you guys
um which shot in the movie ended up
being the toughest to pull off and why
you tried to teach me some of your
spells I found that oh yes I do a lot of
spell casting in the film and I worked
with this lovely choreographer to create
unique gestures for each spell and I
know a bit of sign language so I try to
incorporate that in it like whatever the
spell does
I try to incorporate the word and sign
language into the gesture of this spell
not for every gesture take that Doctor
Strange
he's actually spelling word
when they have magic powers and they
just go like this I was like I want
everything to be unique and creative so
that remembering like which
uh like like the the spoken word of the
spell goes with which gesture and at
what time and then there's a whole
sequence well I don't spoil it away
yeah but that was pretty I guess it
wasn't difficult that was just fun but I
think reggae found it difficult to learn
that no I mean I was I was impressed
with the choreography of it I mean I
mean and you just get that one the
active studio with Justin Smith by the
way like yeah it's a studio like
everything needs to be something there's
a depth tool
s hell yeah
uh the most difficult shots pull off is
pretty much any of them where the whole
group is together keeping a straight
face is very very difficult with this
guy
um but hopefully that translates to
people watching us um because it is very
funny it was very funny and was
distractingly funny on Set uh so
hopefully as long as we kind of get
through I think the cut points are
normally when one of us cracks up and
they're like well this shot is now
useless we have to cut away yeah I have
to go on that note I'm just going to say
Enjoy ccxp you're going to have a
[ __ ] blast